I don't know why this is being delayed.
I don't know why we're having so much so
many issues facing giving this
presentation, but it kind of spells out
exactly where we are in the world and
where it's going and what the plan is of
the occult. And so this will show you
pretty much everything you're wanting to
know. Yeah, at least for me, it spelled
it all out.
So, let's go ahead and connect some of
those dots and begin to dive into the
understanding of what the cosmic egg is
and what it means. Yeah. So, why are we
talking about an egg? What's what does
the egg have to do with our current time
or anything, if you've paid attention,
Trump is talking about 2025 is the
golden age. We keep hearing that term
golden age. Look it up. Just just type
in new age golden age and you will see
that the golden age is a esoteric term
for entering into the age of Aquarius
which is a mind shift of humanity where
we're entering into the age of
enlightenment and it's supposed to
happen anywhere from 2025 to 2030. And
it's like I've been saying this for
months that I think 2025 is like the
beginning of the end because every the
stage is being set. I mean, they keep
saying, "We we see things flying around
in the sky. We don't know what they
are." And the military is like, "We
don't know what they are, but they're
here and they're they seem to be man
benevolent. They seem to be okay. So,
don't worry. Just keep shopping." And
yeah, there's things flying around. So,
things are flying around the sky. We
don't know what they are. They're
supernatural spiritual beings entering
into the the golden age. And we keep
seeing this egg symbolism everywhere.
KFC had a golden egg and the the UFO
that was captured. The the whistleblower
came out and said, "I I found an egg, a
20- foot egg, and I carried it and it
overwhelmed me with emotion. I was
crying and I felt sad at the same time
and joy and song and all these things."
And the interviewer said, "Was it
loving?" He said, "Oh, it was the most
amazing love I've ever felt. It felt
like God." And then there was another
egg that may or may not be legit, but it
was same type of thing, a night vision
goggles that they saw it in Alaska or
Antarctica. And then yeah, we had this
golden egg here and this dystopian
commercial where it's a cult in the
woods and this I'd say that looks like
20 foot egg
that they're lifting up in worship. Why?
Where did this egg come from? from the
heavens, it dropped down. What does this
have to do with where we're at right
now? What is the history, the esoteric
history of this egg from the heavens,
right? And where is this all heading?
Well, first we know that
everything in their agenda is about
programming. Y and so they are actually
telling, like I said, they're telling us
what's to come. They're programming us
ahead of time through little bits of
inundation and exposure to get us
ready to get used to these symbols, to
the meaning of them, to where we're
going. It's like subconscious in some
ways, too. Yeah. And so it is it's in
their mind it's like it is time. It is
now. And we'll see why that is. Where
where where are they leading us?
So in Hinduism, you have the golden egg
or
womb and it represents the beginning of
a divine cycle. They usually refer to
time in cycles instead in the occult.
And so the occult philosophies often
interpret it as a transition into a new
age of enlightenment.
Many esoteric traditions believe we are
moving into a prophesied golden age
which is described as number one the
world religions will merge. All faiths
will be integrated under a single
universal doctrine
and number two the divine androgyny will
be exalted.
The male female divide will be dissolved
into a single cosmic unity reflecting or
sorry reflected in modern gender
blurring movements. We've already seen
that. It's been happening for a while.
They've been leading up to that pushing
it. And number three, a one world leader
will arise. This figure often
anticipated by globalists esotericists
and the Vatican is seen as the
enlightened one who will oversee the new
age. I will add in there oversee the new
age movement. Yeah. So this is
consistent with the esoteric
interpretations of revelation. This is
how they see it. Where the beast or
antichrist will unite the world under a
false religion reflecting the same
cosmic duality taught in occult
traditions.
So I see a a comment here says Trump
says two genders. I don't know if I
missed something else that's going on,
but this is what we expect to see.
There's going to be a pendulum effect
going on
before all of this happens before Satan
appears as Christ to deceive the entire
world. We know that there's going to be
How do you How do you prepare people to
embrace and accept a savior? It's order
out of chaos. Yes. So, they are creating
the chaos. They're creating the problem
so that they can bring about the
solution. Which may I add real quick is
the name of their game. That is the
entire almost rules for their games is
order out of chaos. Create like he's
saying the chaos and have some solution
for the order to come that sets up new
principles in our society to get us
closer to what they want to do. Right?
So if you look at all the presidents
over time, it's always been left, right,
left, right, left, right, because that's
how they prevent the people from forming
an uprising. They put their person in.
It's not you. It's not your vote. They
put their person in and one side is
going to be ticked off. The left is
going to be ticked if it's a Republican
and the right's going to be ticked if
it's a Democrat. But guess what? By the
time four years is up before an uprising
happens, oh no, now you get your guy. So
now you you appease the side that's
ticked off and it and rolls reverse. But
all they do is they pull back on on
little things that don't even matter. So
they've created all this chaos and Trump
gets in and he goes, "Oh no, we're going
to get rid of all that woke stuff. Nope.
Two genders. No more woke stuff." That's
a no-brainer. Like we should not even be
cheering that. I mean, it's a good
thing, but we shouldn't think this is
some
major shift in humanity. Like, oh yes,
we're back to two genders and we're not
cutting genitals off of children and
we're not putting all this woke garbage
in cartoons. That should have already
been that way. And now everybody's so
appeased that we're not even paying
attention to what's really going on.
Yes. So even though Trump is going to
give us some of the normaly back,
better gas prices, better groceries,
it's going to get good. Doesn't mean I
will just put it out there that he is
the savior that he is leading us in the
right direction. He's that's the
distraction he's providing. It means
they know exactly that was the order
that they they just created the chaos.
Now, he is the order that is being used
at that moment in time in their timeline
to create the new age push right now for
this cosmic egg or golden
age phase to come. Yep. I'm not trying
to set dates. I don't believe in that.
But I do believe that 2025 is like the
beginning of the end because esoteric
people, occultists have been prophesying
this for Satan has a game plan, too.
He's got a playbook. He's got his
prophecies and he's been telling his
prophets that 2025 is a big deal. That
you're going to see the externalization
of the hierarchy. Demons literally
manifesting in our world. Well, what
just happened? We got UFOs all over and
we don't even know. The military says we
don't know what they are, but they're
here. Called them drones. It's lit.
Yeah, they they called them drones. That
drones is like um calling them weather
balloons, you know. It's just it's just
the the coverup story that the news puts
out there. They the whole game of the
UFO thing is to make the people feel
like they're tracking. Make the people
feel like the power is in their hands so
they can say, "We demand to know the
truth. You better tell us the truth
about UFOs." When really it's all just a
bunch of misinformation and
disinformation here and there. I
remember when I saw the alien autopsy
come out on Fox and I was like, "It's
real." Like there, you need to tell us
the truth, dude. I fell for it. The
mainstream media does not put out leaks.
It doesn't happen like that. If you're a
true whistleblower, you are on the run
like Snowden. You're not on Fox. And so
they're putting all this stuff out there
to make you believe that this is real
and that you as a citizen demand and you
need to know the truth. And so we will
the the people will say we demand to
know the truth. And they'll say, "Okay,
we've been in communication with
non-human intelligences since the
1930s." They're saying this right now in
congressional hearings. So they're
telling us we talk to interdimensional
beings. They call them that. We're
entering into the golden age and things
are going to get good and so it's going
to look good for a while. It's going to
look
like
well utopia being set up again. Yeah.
Again. And when they say peace and
safety, the Bible says there'll be
sudden destruction. Right. We got to get
into this. Yeah. Sorry. We got to get
into it because we're kind of leaking
some information and then not connecting
everything right now.
But there's this idea of the cosmic
egg. So, let's read more about it. The
cosmic egg, reebus, and the sacred
androgyny. I asked or I just saw someone
asking about the androgyny, how it fits
in. Again, I'm going to go ahead and
tell you that if you really want to hone
in on that part of
things, I do an entire show, which is
quite lengthy on the androgyny. why it
matters in their mythologies and their
beliefs and also why we have seen and
are seeing still
um this idea of LGBTQ and acceptance of
that idea. Well, that show will cover
that for you. So, back to where we're
at. This is all a part of this idea. The
cosmic egg contains the reebus and the
sacred androgyny and they all point
towards a deceptive unity. So just
listen. It is a counterfeit of God's
creation where Satan seeks to unify
humanity under a false golden age. The
golden womb is not just a a Hindu symbol
but a representation of this anticipated
rebirth into a higher consciousness. A
world where all
distinctions spiritual, sexual and
moral, are erased in favor of ecumenical
monism. So ecumenical means all the
world comes together. Monism is we we
explained this a little bit as being all
religions backgrounds and spiritual
beliefs coming together being tolerated
or even um seen as equal to get you to
God.
That is the way any of those ways are a
single religion like coexist movement
that is then
um set up respected and all gets you to
God the god whatever god that is. I hope
that makes sense. But as it it clarifies
in the last sentence there, it says,
"This is the final deception leading
into the rise of the Antichrist and the
ultimate rebellion against God's true
order." The year 2025 holds significant
spiritual and esoteric implications also
across various traditions with themes of
transformation, completion, and
unification emerging prominently. Here's
why. Because in in numerology 2025
reduces to the number 9. Breaking 2025
down you have the 2 0 2 and 5 added
together equals 9 symbolizing completion
humanitarianism and spiritual growth. A
9year is viewed as the culmination of a
full cycle in the occult way of viewing
time encouraging reflection closure and
the release of outdated paradigms. Now,
this outdated paradigm would be I'll
just spill those facts to you. It would
be to let go of the Christian belief of
who God is, right? The Bible, his
commandments, and that we believe in the
type of God that we do. They want us to
believe in a different God. This period
emphasizes global unity, collective
healing, and the potential for societal
shifts towards greater compassion and
understanding. So that is what they're
going to push it all under is that if
you do not let everyone have their own
way of getting to God or their own um I
guess sex or whatever it is
then and and be a part of this global
unity then you are not being
compassionate right and understanding.
Yeah. You're not loving this. This is so
crazy because here it's talking about
uh doing away with what was it? So
spiritual, sexual, and moral is all
going to come together. And that's
exactly what they've been trying to tear
down piece by piece was at one point
they they legalized gay marriage, even
though that wouldn't have been accepted
in the 80s or even the '9s, they they
tested the waters. The public embraced
it because of all the propaganda that
was out um with, you know, Britney
Spears kissing Madonna and Christine
Aguilera and all that stuff. They kept
pushing this stuff out in mainstream
media and even Disney would have a
character who came out of the closet and
they're like, "Oh, well, you shouldn't
hide it." And all this stuff. There was
all this sympathy about this alternative
lifestyle. That's what they call it now.
What used to be once was open sin and
disgusting and all these things. Now
it's just an alternate lifestyle. Love
is love. Who am I to judge? You know, so
they did away with that. Then it was
like, well, there's 86 genders and the
gender is fluid and we don't really, you
know, we don't we don't uh comply to
those barbaric, archaic beliefs like
there's only two genders and that males
have to do this thing and females have
to do this thing. So they're piece by
piece you can see they're getting rid of
these things so that we can all blend
spiritually, sexually and morally which
is religious which I don't know why this
is also coming to mind but if you read I
think 40 or 50 years in the church of
Rome by Charles
Chiniki please go read that book it's
amazing by the way he actually will
explain he became a priest and during
his time of going to become a
priest. A very short story. Uh one of
the other
young men there becoming priests
wandered into his
bedroom of the that persuasion wanting
to have sex with him in his bed. And as
he felt his hands, the young boy's hands
kind of get around him, he jumped and he
screamed.
And when everyone wondered in his kind
of dormatory what
happened the the high I don't know what
the the the actual priest over the
entire dormatory which is like the
father right father so and so came
running and he said why do you refuse
his love brotherly love brotherly love
my goodness so love is love is it
actually came when I think of that term
it always comes from that book because
to them Love is love is love. It doesn't
matter who comes at you, whether it's an
alien, bisexual,
transgender, trans animal, an animal or
a transhuman type of I don't know
machine and human mix or whatever comes
at you, you are supposed to be willing
to give love to it, meaning sex.
And um he was shocked. He did not give
into that. He was shocked at the
father's response to say that he should
be willing to engage in that to receive
the other man's love. And so that's
that's where I'm getting with this. Just
that was a huge example that finally
connected those dots for me. Someone
said, "Same with nuns." That is correct.
Oh yeah, they do that in their order as
well. Um but yeah, I think we can get
back to what we were on. So I did want
to point that out. You know, as we have
compromised on sex and morals, you know,
because gender and sex, it all is under
under morals too. Morality, what's right
and wrong, you know, they're even
starting
to call these things minority attracted
persons, pedophiles, minority attracted
persons. So once you get once you erase
some of these things then the spiritual
I mean we already see so much new age
belief in the church right now and it's
going to be it it's going to allow us to
embrace this whole ecumenical monism
which is all gods are the same all
religions lead to the same god. Yes.
Okay. So to clarify what the cosmic egg
is, um we might have not mentioned this
time that it can be called the orphic
egg, the cosmic egg, philosophers's egg,
or mundane egg. Um those are the names
that come to mind that I've found in
research. But it clarifies and says it
is a potent symbol in various esoteric
traditions representing the origin of
the universe and the unity of all
existence. In alcheal symbolism, the
cosmic egg embodies the idea of a
primordial source from which does that
ever ring a bell? Like primordial ooze
when they talk about evolution as well.
Exactly. All right. So, of a primordial
source from which all creation emerges.
This is often depicted through the
reebus. We will explain what that is,
but they're going to give us a little
bit now. an androgynous figure
symbolizing the harmonious union of
opposites, male and female, like the
baffiment. Yeah. And they're split down
the middle in the picture of the reebus,
you'll see, which is spiritual and
material. The reebus stands within an
oval representing the cosmic egg and
holds symbols like the compass and
square denoting the synthesis of
different realms.
All
right, this is very random, very dark,
but it pertains to this because when
they carry out what they call the
philosopher stone ritual, it has to do
with sex to accomplish this so-called
union of
opposites. And it says right here from
from someone in the
occult, the philosopher stone is the
seaman. He who practices sexual magic
every day is working with the
philosopher's stone. This seed is the
cubic stone of Ysad, the cup of Hermes.
They're selling the book which okay. So
when you start looking at this, we're
going to get into sex magic. It does
have lots of ties to this as well.
Philosopher stone is alchemy. Alchemy is
the blending
of spiritual well the occult and
science. Yeah. And so that's what all
this is about. All this transgender,
transhuman singularity, all this stuff
that we're racing towards right now and
calling it the golden age.
Yeah. So this is Reebus there. There's
the actual picture of
Reebus and they're all in this egg. I
will read below it. It says in the myth
from Arcadia as retold by Robert Graves,
the goddess
Uranome appeared appearing as a dove
laid what had to have been tr a truly
gigantic egg on the cosmic
ocean. Then her serpent consort which is
consort is like your partner or your
spouse your lover wrapped himself around
the egg to incubate it until it hatched.
So you go from a goddess, goddess is
usually human in some form,
to having had a child with a serpent
consort and he wraps himself around the
egg to incubate it until it hatches.
When it did, the entire cosmos spilled
out. All the stars and planets, the moon
and the sun, came from that primordial
egg. You know, I actually know
Christians who believe that Eve had sex
with the serpent. That this whole tree
of knowledge thing was a metaphor. Mhm.
And because it even talks about the
serpent, the seed of the serpent. So,
there's people that believe, even
Christians, who believe that Eve was
impregnated by both Adam and the
serpent. Oh my goodness. Together. And
that's and that she actually had twins
which was Cain and Abel. And Cain was
the seed of the serpent and Adam was or
Abel was the seed of Adam. Right. But
this this is showing you how esoteric
this is the esoteric belief that even
Christians are believing. Yeah. And
where this is all coming from. So that
can be all crazy. I've heard all kinds
of things like that. But yes, that does
exist in their occult knowledge or
thoughts as well sometimes. But that's
not the main doctrine of thought. We're
te we're teaching you the main
uh doctrine of thought there. So in the
context of sex magic within oult
practices, the cosmic egg and the reebus
symbolize the transformative power of
uniting dualities.
Sexual rituals are viewed as a means to
achieve spiritual enlightenment and
personal transformation by harnessing
sexual energy to transcend ordinary
reality. You'll find out why they want
to transcend ordinary
reality. This process is believed to
lead to a state of wholeness often
referred to as the creation of the
divine
hermaphrodite representing the complete
integration of all aspects of the self.
The culmination of these practices and
symbols points towards a form of monism.
There you go. We hear it again. A phil
philosophical viewpoint that all things
are derived from a single substance or
reality. In this context, spiritual,
physical, and sexual energies are seen
as interconnected facets of the same
universal essence. The integration and
harmonization of these energies through
esoteric practices
aim to achieve a unified, listen to
this, unified state of being reflecting
the original wholeness. They're going to
refer to that again symbolized by the
cosmic egg. So, there was a state of
wholeness they're going to talk about
within the egg that they want to get
back to. Yeah. Notice, let me go back to
this. Notice it's talking about physical
and sexual energies are interconnected
facets. And it's saying that this is an
esoteric practice. It might sound
shocking and
uh politically incorrect to say this,
but homosexual sex is an esoteric
satanic practice. Yeah. It's not just an
alternative lifestyle. It's not just
like, oh, well, you know, I love this
person and no, it's literally satanic.
Alistister Crowley wrote about it. Mhm.
He said the best way to skip all the
steps of trying to make magic happen,
like, oh, I can cast this spell and mix
this potion and do all this, is to just
have uh homosexual sex. Mhm. It's called
sex magic. He figured out, he wrote a
whole book on sex magic, and it was all
about skipping all these steps. Well,
and I'll throw in there, magic with a K.
Actually, in all occult knowledge, if it
has a K with it, it is about sex. magic
always. They don't even have to say sex
magic, just magic with a K. And if you
remember, if you're old enough to
remember and was in that genre or
whatever, there was a a band called Red
Hot Chili Peppers. They might even be
around today, they had an album called
Blood, Sex, Magic, and it was spelled
with a K. It's even says Sex Magic. They
made it like it was three words, blood,
sex, magic, but it's literally one
phrase, blood, sex, magic with a K. Mhm.
Okay. So, here we get to see it a little
clearer, enlarged. You have the male and
female sharing one body called the
reebus. The sun is behind him. The moon
is behind her. He's holding the compass.
She's holding the square. These little
um stars basically or hexogs there.
One's a female, one's a male. Then
they're united into the symbol above
them which actually is called the
reebus. Oh yeah. This symbol. And on the
side there you have a few of the planets
because along with the moon and the sun
you have this the planets kind of being
woripped in the occult. Also you may
have heard men are from Mars, women are
from Venus. It all goes back to this
stuff, right? So then you have the
dragon they're standing on that's
breathing fire. You have the earth is
what they're on a globe. They're
standing on that with wings. And there's
symbology of of course the shapes that
are inside of that. They will explain
that later, but it they're already
putting this together. And it's true. It
all goes back to Freemasonry also. And
you have the hexog or the, you know, we
know that symbol by the star of David
supposedly um for the
Jews.
And you know, both of these are in on
that like it's a part of this. It's a
hexog. That is a hexog symbol right
there. Someone's asking about the the
serpent. The serpent will be in another
image, I hope. But if not, that's right.
You look up the cosmic egg, the mundane
egg, especially the mundane. There's a
serpent wrapped. This right here, this
oval. Yes. This is the egg. They are
inside the egg. the the whole cosmos is
inside the egg. Which is interesting
because the people that came up with
this understood bib biblical cosmology.
They understood the way the world works
where all the cosmos is inside of the
firmament. And that that that'll be
brought up later. But yeah, the the
snake wraps around this egg right here.
Yeah, that's another way that they
illustrate the cosmic egg is just a big
egg with this neck. the snake wrapped
around it.
So to add to the understanding of this
um it says the center focus of the flash
the reebus is the alcheml androgyny a
figure of sublime union balancing the
very nature of existence in one
perfectly united unified form. So I'll
skip down from there. This particular
image shows the reebus standing upon a
dragon breathing flame. So this is
actually the image I've only seen. I
don't know that there's any others
showing the reebus. But it also says the
dragon in this context is one of the
tria primma sulfur the potential of the
spirit shown through transformative
flame. Now we were just going to mention
this. I'll just add it now. when you
have Chris Bledsoe talking about
um having had talks with UFOs and aliens
and this big egg that that came towards
him that an alien came out of I think is
what he said. Yeah. You have that
instance. Then you have um Jake Barb
Barber Barber who was one of those
intelligence people I believe carrying
or flying a 20ft egg um in a mission
that he was doing to retrieve it and he
he talks about this big egg. So when
you've come to the knowledge like Mikey
has on UFOs and alien encounters,
there's usually a sulfur smell left
behind. they encounter the humans that
are dealing with these and also in demon
encounters. That's the weird part.
There's always this sulfur smell as
well. I can't say always, but I should
say that it's been very common in their
stories. um the two of them UFO alien
encounters and as I'm counting that as
one type of encounter and then in demon
encounters as well and people associate
that with uh God destroying Sodom
Gomorrah and other cities with balls of
fire they found these sulfur balls
actually if you you hear about um when
people say fire and brimstone what is
brimstone I don't even know it's sulfur
I didn't know that but brimstone you
always hear that term fire and brimstone
that's uh sulfur actually
right so lastly last paragraph here I
should say it says supporting the reebus
is the globe of the earth within it are
the square and triangle together the
circle the square and the triangle are
the greatest of all shapes to the
alchemist the square is the corpse the
triangle the spirit and the circle is
the realm of the divine so the trying to
get back to the divine. They're trying
to put all this together. And it says,
"The wings attached to the globe
reiterate the transcendental quality of
these
figures." And
so I guess that's all they have to add
to that. But so slowly we're going to
get more of an understanding on this.
This is a little bit more that they add
on it within the square.
is the number 43. Did you see that
before? It was there. This has a twofold
meaning. Let's go back. I didn't notice
actually. So, yeah, the number 43 right
there.
Okay. Firstly, it is a degree of
measurement. Another concept very
important to
alchemists. Um, and I will add that
sacred geometry. So, geometry is very
important to occultists as well. That's
a whole another science that they have
in the occult. But if you really put
them together, you have another practice
of why you have pentagrams and hexag and
all this stuff and seals of Solomon that
are all different shapes. You have
geometry coming in. And secondly, it sum
is seven, the most perfect number
ascribed to the divine. One can also
observe that the four rests within the
square while the three is similarly
placed within the triangle. As to
further play significance on
measurement, the female holds in her
hand a
square and the man holds a
compass. Today, the square and compass
are more visibly identified with the
esoteric order of the Freemasons who use
it for the teachings of metaphysical
concepts as well as using it as a
constant reminder of the necessity to
keep good judgment and
morality. I want to go ahead and
comment. I don't know why this is coming
to mind also, but metaphysics
when you think of that word, I don't
don't quote me on this, but when I first
heard
it, it was
a nature path type
doctor who was kind of um trying to
encourage me to use what sounded like
and indeed was hypnotism
to accomplish some health in some I
guess get overhealth problems that was
going on and they called it no no no no
it's not hypnotism it's not any weird
voodoo weird stuff it's called
metaphysics
and so that's when I finally started
realizing that several people in the new
age or witches and warlocks um are kind
of masquerading as your nature paths and
your
uh clean natural medicine doctors
under the name they're using they're
clarifying it and using this this excuse
that it is science. It is true science.
It is just called metaphysics. Yeah. So
that's why it is um credible to use and
therefore it'll help everything.
So that's where I heard it and it was
being pushed in my life. I don't know if
you've kind of heard of it other ways,
other places, but I don't see it as a
very positive thing because of that.
Um, not all, I should say, not all
holistic um or nature path doctors even
know what they're doing if they do
practice some of these things. But even
I was looking into it. I actually do
counsel people on health because I'm a
functional
nutritionist. And you didn't know that,
I'm sure. off to the side. Um, but I was
looking into it in college to become a a
natural doctor because I didn't want to
deal with pharmaceuticals. I would not
prescribe that to someone. So, I was
looking at the alternatives. How do I do
this and please God and not give into
new age practices being pushed into
natural medicine?
And so I actually couldn't I couldn't
find a program that would not allow me
to even get the title and the degree
certificate without doing some form of
yoga hypnotism
um united prayer or uh mind mindfulness
is what they call it that is not right
before God. And so I could not pursue
being a doctor at all.
Wow. And um just something to think
about. I know that I do practice a form
of natural medicine right now that I
believe in, but it's lifestyle, diet,
and supplements, and that's all I found
that works. So, just a plug for that.
I'm sorry. I didn't mean to get into
this, but it just made me think of all
of that. Something for you to think
about, too. And um we can go ahead and
get back to the last. That's
soozobbody.com. s o zobbody.com.
Thank you.
Okay. No, no, we have to read the
bottom. Okay. So, the very last
paragraph there says, "Surrounding the
reebus is a semicircle." Oh, we did.
Okay. Are seven
figures for the seven classical planets
cuz planets come into this and planet
worship too. Five of these seven are
inscribed with their planetary influence
while the parent metals of the seven
soul and luna are shown as the sun and
the moon. So metals to the alchemist
matter and kind of coexist with the
planets
um to accomplish some of this in their
rituals. Once again, this concept of
seven being a figure of transformation
and divinity
re-emerges. Oh, and thank you. Real
quick, someone said Een Patterson said
here the word holistic depends on who is
a practitioner. That is correct. You
will find that you have to ask every
holistic or naturopathic person what
they mean by what they practice. You
need to ask them all of it up and down
and all around to make sure that they do
not have something weird that they
practice. Very good point.
Oh, someone says, "Please put a link." I
didn't catch that. I did. Okay.
All right. So to prove this point about
the
egg, we have Helen Blovatsky who founded
the Theosophical Society or Theosophy.
She's big in the new age. She's one of
their quoted
um what shall we say channelers and and
um patriarchs. There we go. And she
says she refers to the egg as a
universal symbol representing the
primordial source from which the deity
which is I guess the god whichever god
it is and the materials for the creation
of the cosmos come into
existence. Crowley then comes on this
scene. He's the one who wrote the
satanic bible. He's the most evil man on
earth in his own words even. Yeah. The
beast 666. wickedest man alive and has
inspired many musicians and celebrities,
right? And he expands upon the teachings
of sex magic within the Ordo
Temply
Orientis associating different sexual
magical techniques with various degrees
of initiation. This
completely is handinhand with
Freemasonry and the Jesuit order.
I don't know if no everyone's new to
that, but they all have these degrees of
initiation based on sexual techniques
and
rituals. He emphasized the use of sexual
energy. This is Alistister Crowley
again. The use of sexual energy as a
potent force for transcending one's
normally perceived reality and achieving
spiritual enlightenment.
And then Alice Bailey, she was also kind
of a new
age pioneer, I guess, for the occult
world. And it says, "While Bailey's work
focused more on a spiritual and esoteric
philos uh psychology, she did discuss
the concept of the solar angel, which
can be related to the idea of a higher
self or soul that guides individual
evolution.
She didn't talk specifically about the
cosmic egg or sexual practices, but that
comes directly from the Lucius Trust.
All
right.
So, Lucius Trust used to be Lucifer
Trust and the United Nations obtained a
lot of her writings and that's how you
can find some of this stuff uh about the
externalization of the hierarchy and all
that kind of stuff. If you you just look
up Luc Lucius trust and you'll find that
stuff, right? Okay. So to prove it
further, we have the cosmic egg
appearing in many ancient traditions
usually as the womb of creation, the
source of divine order and the beginning
of all things. It is often associated
with the birth of gods, humanity and
entire universes.
Similarly, the golden age is is viewed
as a return to the original state. This
is very interesting and you need to know
this. It's a return to the original
state of perfection that they believe
came before corruption, duality and
decay entered the world.
So we can see this in Hinduism where
they call it the golden womb which
contains the universe and their ideas
and from it emerged the Brahma the
creator initiating the first cosmic
cycle. The Hindu golden age is called
Satya Yuga and is said to be a time when
truth unity and divine order prevailed
before gradual decline. Now one thing to
mention when you do believe in the
Hinduistic
beliefs you are coming back through
karma reincarnation and their different
levels of initiation again and rituals
you want to become your own Brahma a
Brahman your own creator other word in
other words your own god you reached the
level of the highest enlightenment
possible
and you become one with this god Brahman
that is right. So there are those points
to consider. Also in Greek and Roman
mythology, the philosopher Hessiod
described the golden age as a time when
gods and humans lived together in
harmony, similar to the primordial state
within the cosmic egg before separation.
So this is what they believe. It was
perfect in that primordial
egg. And in her medicicism and alchemy,
the philosopher<unk>'s egg symbolizes
the perfection of the great work which
seeks to return mankind to its divine
enlightened state. So there's another
clue as to what they're getting at. They
believe that mankind can be divine. Yep.
Used to be divine and used to be divine
in its enlightened state. And now we are
all somehow asleep to our our godliness
our um enlightenment that we need to all
obtain. So also in the cabala the sof or
infinite unknowable god itself is to
create the primordial space for the
universe mirroring the cosmic egg's role
in creation. The messianic age in Jewish
mysticism is a return to divine unity, a
form of the golden age. Thus, the cosmic
egg represents the original wholeness
from which the golden age is birthed or
restored. So, this is what they call the
golden age. Yeah. So, somebody in here
said, uh, yoga. Shannon
said yoga. That's exactly right. Yoga
means to yoke. Yes. What are you yoking
with? You're yoking with Brahman.
Brahma. So here it says in the new age
context, Brahman is often understood as
the universal consciousness or the
underlying reality that permeates all of
existence. New age practitioners may
view Brahman as the ultimate source of
all things, a divine energy or a unified
field of energy that connects
everything. The goal is often seen as
realizing one's oneness with Brahman.
That's the yoking right there. So, if
you are a
Christian practicing yoga, please stop.
We've never made a video on exposing
yoga, but sometimes we kind of think
some of this stuff is obvious, but it's
it's not. So, it's getting into
churches. Churches are inviting women
for yoga and all this stuff, but but I
will it's a spiritual it's a religion.
Yeah. And I will add that Alistister
Crowley used yoga every single day.
three different forms and sessions of
yoga daily to communicate with the
demons. Yeah. That's how he prepared his
mind to do so. Yeah. This this
is positions that are glorifying pagan
gods. That's why you have the sun
salutation. You're literally saluting
the sun god.
uh all the poses are literally
uh I can't think of the right word but
you're giving reverence to false idols
false gods
right
okay so further both cabalistic and
Hindu traditions utilize the metaphor of
a cosmic egg to convey the emergence of
multiplicity from
unity in cabala the ein sof's
self-contra
action ooh creates a space for the
universe to unfold akin to a cosmic egg
hatching into the tree of life with its
interconnected sephoru
sephurat representing various aspects of
existence. Similarly in
Hinduism the I guess the tree of life
embodies the universe's potential
hatching to manifest all forms and
beings. Oh that was the egg. Okay. These
parallels highlight a shared
understanding of the universe as a
unified whole originating from a
singular infinite source. So inso since
we're on the topic of yoga and all that
too connecting with this
egg can be accomplished actually through
the chakras again in the pelvic region
where it starts. So it's the chakra
number one. Mhm. The Capalis tree
actually will show you and in in Judaism
that it begins with usually sexual
practices as well. Yeah. Somebody in
here was saying
um yoga. Oh yeah. In yoga the serpent
wraps around and up wraps around and up
the spine. Yeah. It's Yeah. So
condundolini yoga that's like the that's
the achievement you want to get. You
want to get this condundolini
awakening. Yeah. where the serpent
literally this is not me. I'm not just
trying to use some scare tactics. This
is in their own writings like you want
the serpent to go up your spine and
enter the crown chakra and which is the
frontal lobe. Yeah. As believers who
have the word of God which is the truth.
That should be red flags going off like
crazy. Now all around the world people
worship dragons and serpents and all
this stuff. But as Christians, we know
that that old serpent who's the dragon
and Satan, the devil, is going to
deceive the entire world. You look all
around the world and see everybody
worshiping dragons and serpents. It's
like boom, the Bible knew this. The
Bible is telling the truth. And so, as a
Christian, when you practice something
where the main goal is for the serpent
to enter into your crown chakra,
that should be red flags like crazy. Get
out of this stuff. Never touch yoga
again. Mhm. If you got some issues where
you need to stretch your spine, all that
stuff, get an inversion table or do
something else. Do not just do regular
stretching quite honestly.
All
right. Um, so I just had to mention that
about Cabalism and Judaism and how
it's Yeah, it is also the chakras and
and sex. So last part we're on here
regarding the concept of monism. Both
traditions suggest a form of spiritual
monism where all aspects of existence
spiritual, physical and even sexual
energies are interconnected expressions
of the same divine reality. In Cabala,
the interplay of the
sephorat includes both masculine and
feminine energies whose harmonious union
is is essential. There you go. Essential
for the balance and sustenance of
creation. In Hinduism, the cosmic egg
contains both female male and female
principles in union symbolizing the
source of all creation.
This union reflects the intrinsic
oneness of all dualities, suggesting
that the ultimate reality transcends
individual distinctions embodying a
holistic unity.
Wow.
Here's a bunch of myths. So, different
kinds of cultures coming from uh that
also believe in the egg. Palasian,
Finnish mythology, Persian, Slavic,
Chinese, Egyptian, Polynesian,
Greek. Oh, there you go. The orphic egg.
Greek orism.
So, there's the picture. Around the egg,
snake around the egg. This is the
mundane egg or the orphic egg. Yes, both
actually. They're all the same. I'll
just say that. But there's the golden
egg in the Hindu Hindu mythology. Golden
egg. The Oh my Dogen. I've never heard
of Dogen mythology. Japanese and Bantto
mythology and good old USA. Kentucky
Fried Chicken. Mhm. All right. So,
that's just an overview for you guys to
get a clear understanding. It kind of
exists in most all cultures and
mythologies around the world.
However, the elements of the cosmic egg,
divine androgyny, and the merging of
dualities, both all of spiritual,
sexual, and
philosophical, are deeply embedded
within the esoteric foundations of new
age thought, Freemasonry, Satanism, the
occult, and certain aspects of
institutional religion such as
Catholicism, Islam, and even some
branches of Christianity.
I'm just going to stop real quick
because some people are asking about
um Tai Chi, I believe. Yeah, Tai Chi and
also Pilates. So, I did Tai Chi for a
little bit when I was a kid, but it
actually did have an effect where I was
being controlled by something and I had
to stop. It was after almost four times
of doing it only. And it unfortunately
is the practice. If you have not already
seen
um the dragon revealed documentaries by
Little Light with Eric Wilson, he
actually goes over all of martial arts
and how Tai Chi fits into that and it
accomplishes the same thing
unfortunately as yoga. So when you look
up uh what what is chi just what is chi
because it's what tai chi uh in
traditional Chinese medicine chi also
spelled with a qi um refers to the vital
life force or energy that flows through
the body and is essential for health and
vitality. Um this is all like magic. I
mean this is this is the same as new age
stuff, the same as believing that you
have power within you. We have no power
of oursel. All any kind of miraculous
supernatural powers come from God or
Satan, right? That's it. And so if you
pray and ask God for a miracle and it
happens, thank God, praise God. Mhm.
Anything else, if you're using herbs,
crystals, chi, yoga, whatever it is,
it's of Satan. And I know that sounds
very narrowminded, but that's the truth.
It is true. But herbs can be used by
God's people as well. God made herbs. I
wasn't saying that. I'm talking about
like burning sage. Burning sage is not
going to run a demon off. Or creating a
mixture of herbs. That's usually what
they call a potion in witchcraft or so
on that creates a spell. They It usually
is a part of a spell. When we take herbs
and supplements, we are taking them the
way I mean it's the way God made it and
you take them and they have the the
effect God meant them to have on your
body. Yeah. Consume them. Don't create
potions and burn them and all these
things. So,
Pilates, I don't know too much about it,
but I also looked into it and
uh I was doing some of that, but I did
learn that it does have some dark roots
as well. And so, I encourage people to
look further
um into that because I
I don't know. Smells good though. It's I
actually love incense and they burn
incense to God in the temple and things
like that. But yeah, sage is not going
to run off any unan unclean spirits,
fallen angels, any of that.
So, good old working out with um I guess
stretching and weights and so on is kind
of what I stick with. Yeah. Just don't
just don't follow a guide, you know?
Just or a master. Yeah. Yeah, you don't
need a master to teach you how would be
good. Um, so let's see here. Where were
we?
Oh yes. So the overarching theme is the
unification of all things into a
singular
entity. U whether that be through the
reebus alchemal hermaphrodite, the
androgynous divine of gnostic and occult
traditions or the cosmic egg birthing
creation. This mirrors the goal of
ecumenical monism, a world where all
spiritual paths and dualities merge into
one universal doctrine. Wow. Where did
you where are you at? Where did you We
are right right here. We started there
and we're down here.
where it
says I don't even know where you saw
that but overarching theme unification
re the overarching theme is the
unification of all things into a
singular entity
we are moving into singularity the
singulararity movement with AI and all
this stuff microchipping our brains all
All languages are understood and
becoming one. This is the new tower of
Babel, the singularity. This is so
crazy. The overarching theme is the
unification of all things into a
singular entity. Right? So, as they
finish this off, and just in case it's
not coming together fully, they say,
"This mirrors the goal of ecumenical
monism, a world where all spiritual
paths and dualities merge into one
universal doctrine." Wow. I know I
already read that but that was religion
powerful. Yeah.
So the unification of male and female a
golden age philosophy
many esoteric traditions including
cabala hermeticism theosophy and
freemasonry focus on the
hyrosamos. Please go watch the
androgyny show because I focused heavily
on this. It is a
high Sabbath, meaning
high witches Sabbath type of ritual that
all of the occult world carries out.
That's so sexual and disgusting. I don't
want to have to explain it over and over
again, but it symbolizes the merging of
male and female forces to create divine
wholeness. In alchemy, this is the
reebus which is depicted standing inside
the cosmic egg. A perfect union of one
of opposites echoing the golden womb of
Hinduism. The golden womb is a vessel
from which creation emerges paralleling
the freemasonic notion of the great
architect shaping the cosmos. And now we
know why they have the checkered floors,
the yin and the yang, all this stuff,
all the sexual stuff. you see all over
the world is all about this. It's about
the merging of opposites, light and
dark. The Bible's so clear. Light cannot
mix with dark. What What fellowship has
light with darkness, darkness with
light? And yet that's what Satan wants
to do. He wants to do anything the
opposite of God's design.
But, and I'm not I'm not even justifying
any of
this, but in the occult, there's always
white magic, black magic, yin andyang,
male and female. Basically, they're
they're mirroring that reebus coming
together good and bad. I'm not saying
male and female, either one is bad, but
putting together all opposites and
dualities to create this singularity
that's happening here.
Yeah. This was a nun that I ran across.
Um I don't know if she's a nun. She was
saint. She was actually a saint. It says
here. Oh, let me go back. So it says
saint.
So yeah, St. Hildigard. She was a German
mystic but also a saint. It's so weird
that we don't think that's unusual to be
a mystic and a so-called Christian in a
Catholic faith or whatever. Well, like I
I just mentioned down below it says St.
Hildgard was a
Benedictine or bectine abbis. So, she
was actually an abbey
uh nun, if you will. Yeah. Well, you can
see what she's wearing. She's wearing a
nun. Uh writer, poet, and composer who
lived in the 12th century Germany. She
had numer So, 12th century means she was
born in the 1100s.
She had numerous prophetic and mystical
visions during her life and is said to
have been a miracle worker. Okay. How
far back does this go? The 11 the
1100s. Look what happened. She had a
dream about this. A vision. And she
painted I thought she painted this as
well. This was a quilt by somebody based
on her vision. But it says the
firmament. Interesting. The Bible talks
about the firmament that the whole
cosmos is inside of the firm firmament
in the likeness of an egg and what is
signified for this vast instrument round
and shadowed in the shape of an egg
small at the top large in the middle and
narrowed at the bottom faithfully shows
omnipotent
God
incomprehensible in his majesty. And see
this sounds so good, right? You hear
these like terms and you think, "Oh,
this is
beautiful." and inestimatable
inestimatable
inestimatable in his mysteries and the
hope of all the faithful for humanity at
first was rude and rough and simple in
its actions but was enlarged through the
old and new testament and finally at the
end of the world is destined to be beset
with many tribulations. She went on in
her quotes to say, I that was a lot to
read just to say that basically that
this egg is the firmament. All the
cosmos is inside of it. Just like we've
been seeing in the esoteric world, this
nun is having these prophetic visions
and seeing the same thing.
Hildigard, the theologian, compared God
to a cosmic egg
that surges flames into the universe,
emptying and and filling itself like a
womb. All this is esoteric, creative,
beneficial, and nurturing to all life
within. She spoke of this sacred
feminine, the sacred feminine as divine
love. This we know that the divine
feminine is all racing right now too.
The essence of the universe, the highest
fiery power that shines in water, burns
in the sun, moon and stars, stirring
everything into existence and causing
all life to glisten with this light.
She's literally explaining what the
occult believes about the origin of our
earth and this cosmic egg and all this
stuff. And she's in the Christian world,
the quote unquote Christian world.
So, this is where it's it's crossing
boundaries of religion. Yes.
And Catholics are well known for
crossing esoteric boundaries and calling
it Christianity. Right. So, she was
bringing that in during her day and uh
yeah, they definitely she told you right
then and there though if she's calling
it God, but it was visions and it's the
cosmic egg, God will never portray
himself as a cosmic egg, right? He's not
going to use esoteric and occult things.
No. To reveal himself. And it's Satan
who copies him. Not not Jesus, not God
who copies Satan.
in their doctrine or or their symbolism.
So, we know exactly she was getting it
from Satan and his demons. All this
information and there's no such thing as
a divine feminine. No, it's God. He's
masculine.
All right. So, this same concept appears
in Catholicism's veneration of Mary as
the queen of heaven alongside Christ,
symbolizing a sacred male and female
union.
Islam's mystical Sufi, maybe I didn't
say that right, Sufi traditions also
emphasize divine androgyny in uniting
the soul with Allah.
Christianity when co-opted by Rome, here
we go. when it was
basically pagan but merged with Rome to
become Christianity. It merged pagan
fertility worship into its transition or
traditions such as the Madonna and child
reflecting Isis and Horus. This aligns
with new age teachings and ecumenical
movements that seek to unite all
religions into a single universal
spirituality.
So I want to comment on something.
There's a comment that came in. It says,
"Silence is eloquence 100%. Don't feed
into this distractor." The thing is
is we are hearing this from Trump. You
know, a lot of Christians are saying,
"Oh, Trump, he's he's he's our guy. He
was put here by God to fix all this." I
mean, there there's so many Christians
that literally idolize this man and they
say, "No, he we we're winning right now.
God is doing something and it's going to
look like that. It's going to appear
that Trump is coming in. He's draining
the swamp. He's getting rid of woke
stuff. He's he's stopping the new world
order. He's even stopping chemtrails."
They say, "Oh, it's literally like in
the news." Well, a guy told us that he's
AI is now going to be able
to cure cancer. You know what I mean?
Like everything he's putting into effect
is gonna sound like it's Oh, Elon Elon
wants to microchip your brain so that
paralyzed people can walk and all this
stuff. It's the same agenda. Yeah. With
with Trump and with the Democrat, it
doesn't matter. Nothing has changed. You
look at Trump's board, it's all the same
stuff. It's AI governance. It's
literally a dystopian world. I'm just
gonna Sorry. I'm going to jump in there.
We'll find out why that is. That's a
part of this as well. There's actually
certain mechanisms
or methods that they're using to
actually create this golden age coming
about as well. So, we will jump into
that. That might actually be on
tomorrow's. We'll find out. Yeah,
tomorrow's going to be a good That is
tomorrow's tomorrow is going to be a
great show. You're going to want to see
that because I hate talking about
politics. I really do. But it's the
leaders of the world. It's what is
Satan's agenda for this earth? And I
hate seeing so many Christians get duped
by this. They're like, "No, he's talking
about God and all this stuff. It's going
to look like worldwide worldwide
revival. It's going to look like coexist
and peace and safety and kumbaya and all
this stuff." The reason we're talking
about this is because we just saw a nun,
a self-professed like Christian who had
the same thing and said it was God. So
this is we're not just diving into
esotericism and saying, "Oh, look what
they believe." And all this stuff. It
it's being pushed on the whole world and
we're trying to warn and wake up the
sleeping giant that this is not
Christian. Even Easter, guys, come on.
Like Easter's coming. Wait, wait. We're
going to be getting into saying this is
what Christians are embracing. Why are
we got the eggs? You know, if you Oh my
goodness. Okay, let's get into it. I
just I don't want people to think we're
just, hey, this is the occult show where
we study what the occult believes. Of
course not. No, we're showing where the
world is going. They believe something
different.
So what is this cosmic egg and cos or
golden age supposed to accomplish? This
is what this slide is about. And they
teach it within their traditions and
mystery schools. And they explain that
they see time as linear, not cyclical.
Meaning that after a period of decline
and destruction, a new age must be born.
The cosmic egg is central to this
rebirth process where the old world must
die. So the new
age, the new golden age can emerge.
Number one, in in Freemasonry and
Theosophy, the age of Aquarius is seen.
It's also called the age of Aquarius. By
the way, the new golden age is also
called age of Aquarius. It is seen as
the next step in spiritual evolution. A
cultists like Alice Bailey and Helen
Bllovadsky spoke of a new world order
guided by a world teacher where all
religious and spiritual traditions unite
into one. Crowleyian and Luciferian
thought teaches or promotes the Aon of
Horus,
a new age of enlightenment where
humanity attains godhood. The egg
appears frequently in Crowley's work
symbolizing the hatching of divine
knowledge. In the new age in ecumenical
monism, the cosmic egg represents a
singularity where male and female, light
and dark, all faiths and ideologies.
Okay. All faiths and ideologies merge
into a singular consciousness, a primary
goal of new age
globalism. The cosmic egg in this view
is the vessel in which humanity is
incubated. awaiting its transformation
into the next state of evolution,
ushering in the golden age. Yeah. So,
yeah. Who's ushering in the golden age?
Trump. What is it? It's all about this
cosmic egg, this symbolic. And even in
the physical world, when we have these
fallen angels traveling around in eggs
and commercials pushing this all in your
face, it's predictive programming. What
is it all about? It's
about uniting us all into one religion.
It's the one world religion that's
coming. Why? How are we how are you
going to fall for it? How how's the
world going to fall for a one world
religion? Because the world is going to
be in such disarray, such chaos, such
fear that we're crying out for a savior.
And who's going to come? Satan as the
cosmic savior of the world to bring
about peace and to p perform lying signs
and wonders, miracle working demons. The
Bible says we have to ignore our senses
and believe what the Bible says. So many
people don't study the Bible. They're
getting their understanding of prophecy
from Left Behind movies and all this
stuff. They are going to fall for the
deception because guess what? Christ
isn't going to touch the earth. He's not
going to be walking around making a new
millennium in here. Jesus said, "When
they say he's in the desert, don't go.
Don't even look. When he say he's in the
secret chambers, don't go because the
deception is so great. You will fall for
it when you see a supernatural being
doing miracles." And so we I believe and
I've said this already and I I still
believe
this. Yes, things are going to get
really good with Trump, but I believe
eventually we're going to start to be
like, "Wait a minute. We fell for the
Antichrist. We thought he was like a
savior, but he's setting up AI
governance. Stargate. Wait a minute.
He's forming a dystopian world. Wait a
minute. We fell for the Antichrist. And
now that the quote unquote Antichrist
has appeared, now the quote unquote real
Christ can come. Right? As Christians,
we know that Christ isn't returning
until there's an antichrist. So, Satan
can't really fool the world until
there's an antichrist to defeat.
So, Trump is going to be put in place. I
hate to say this so
um so like matterofactly because I I
don't know that it's going to be Trump.
He looks like he's going to be the key
player. If 2025 is really like the the
beginning of this and he's pushing this
whole new age of Aquarius and all this
stuff, it looks like Trump will be set
up as
this, oh, we fell for the Messiah, but
he's not really the Messiah. He's the
Antichrist. And then Satan can come in
and defeat the quote unquote Antichrist
and all the world will wonder after what
appears to be the true
Christ. Satan doing all
these He's an angel of light. He can do
miracles. He can bring out fire from
heaven. He look at how he affle
afflicted Job, put sores on him, all
this
stuff. It says that there's going to be
miracle working demons in the last days.
We We cannot believe our senses even. We
have to understand what the Bible says
about prophecy or we will be deceived.
Mhm.
Okay, here we go. We have a video. So,
check this clip out because recently.
Yeah, this is this year, January or the
end of last year. I can't remember. It
was the end of 2024 or the beginning of
2025, but this is the type of stuff that
we're hearing now.
Pope Francis spoke to young people at an
interreligious gathering
because every religion is a way to
arrive at
God sort of a comparison. And an example
would be they're sort of like different
languages in order to arrive at God.
But God is is God for
all. for all then we're all sons and
daughters of God.
But my God is more important than your
God.
Is that true?
There's only one God and each of us is a
language so to speak in order to uh
arrive at God.
Muslim
there. There are different paths.
Dude, he literally pointed out he said
Muslim, Christian, Hindu. I mean, that's
monotheism. Whenever you look it up,
monotheism, it's those three symbols
uniting.
He's dude, he is setting it up right
now. And every world ruler goes and
flies to meet the pope and bows to him
and shakes his hand and kiss his ring.
All this stuff. So if you think, "Oh,
that's just the pope saying that. Who is
he?" According to biblical pro bible
prophecy, Rome is the world power. I
mean, America is like the superpower,
but Rome's like the the hidden power.
What's the world's largest Christian
denomination? Catholicism. What does
Catholic mean? universal
ecumenical and dude this is crazy how
this is just coming out right in our
faces.
[Music]
Mhm.
Okay. So the connection between the
cosmic egg and the golden age is also
evident in
alchemyism Hindu
esotericism which describe an ultimate
divine rebirth. The golden egg of
Hinduism, as we mentioned before, is the
golden womb gives birth to the
universe. And the golden age as a return
to the unified god state is seen with
the egg representing undivided
potential. And cracking it open leads,
here we go. They're telling us exactly
where they want us to go. Cracking it
open leads to a new level of
consciousness. The very goal of the
occult great works. They want that for
every man and woman
everywhere. Luciferian initiation,
enlightenment is the idea of becoming as
gods. Yeah. Align with the golden age, a
time when man is no longer limited by
moral constraints. Here we go. No
morals, but reaches divine status.
Biblically and prophetically, the cosmic
egg symbolism could align with the
coming deception of a new golden age.
One that appears to be a utop be
utopian, but is actually the final
rebellion against God.
The antichrist and the one world
religion. Many new age and occult
teachings foresee a global leader who
will unite the world under a single
spiritual system often aligning with the
cosmic egg's symbolism of merging all
into
one. Revelation's counterfeit kingdom.
The idea of a new enlightened humanity
echoes the antichrist's false kingdom. a
deceptive golden age where mankind
believes it has ascended beyond God's
laws. Wow. In Freemasonry and Luciferian
influence, which is in the Vatican, it
says, "Wow, the push for interfaith
unity, universalism, and
ecumenicism,
ecumenism, h I always get tripped up on
all these big words sometimes. aligns
with occult doctrines of merging all
paths into one. The very goal of the
cosmic egg philosophy
all to one.
So I think it's interesting that Pope
Benedict uh in 2012 was presented a 200
kilo Easter egg by new Bulgarian
President Rosen. So you'll see right
here
So yeah, here here's this big egg. Why?
Why? Why an egg? Why don't you give him
a a dove or something? Some kind of
representation of the Holy Spirit or I
don't know, a cross even would make
sense in a church. Why an egg?
Golden egg. Yeah, it's golden, too. Oh
my goodness. It's right there. because
this has all been Satan's plan for a
long
time.
Okay, so here's where we get to Easter
and it says the concept of the cosmic
egg appears to have a direct connection
to Easter, particularly in how ancient
fertility and rebirth symbolism was
absorbed into Christian quote unquote
Christian traditions. The egg as a
symbol of resurrection, renewal, and
creation has deep roots in pagan
traditions and occult esoteric systems.
And these influences can be traced back
to Babylonian, Egyptian, and other
mystery uh mystery
religions. Now, I'm going to add right
here, and I don't know if I have it. Oh,
it mentions it below. I won't mention it
right now, I guess. But here we see that
the the egg has long been a symbol of
fertility, rebirth and creation in
various ancient
cultures. Many of these traditions were
later synretized into Christianity
particularly particularly through
Catholicism. Number one, you have
Babylonian roots where Ishtar and
Tamuz and the name Easter is often
linked to
Ishtar. The Babylonian goddess of
fertility, war, and love. According to
legend, Ishtar's sacred egg, and this is
true, listen up. Ishtar's sacred egg in
mythology fell from heaven into the
Euphrates River, symbolizing divine
birth and cosmic renewal.
Wait. So, I just want you to to read
that again because Ishtar, who's a false
god, which is a an unclean spirit, a
fallen angel, Mhm. masquerading as a
woman, came in an egg and fell from
heaven. Okay. Just just remember that a
fallen angel in an egg coming to earth.
Does that sound familiar? Yeah. Yeah. I
mean even in the Morin Mindy and this
this was in Babylonian
times way back when. So in Egyptian and
Greek mythology you have the phoenix a
bird that regenerates from its own
ashes was sometimes depicted emerging
from a cosmic egg reflecting the idea of
resurrection. That's the rising phoenix.
the fiery phoenix that you see even at
the 9/11 ceremony and all that.
Yes. And here's what I was getting at.
The egg in Druidic and Norse traditions.
The Druids used eggs as part of their
fertility rituals. That's not only it,
although they only mention that here.
They also carried around an egg. Most of
them had runes or satanic symbols on
them
um to show that they were druids. This
was like this is my
god. Here's a image of
it. I want to do a ritual or show other
people what I am. And they continue on
by saying, "While Norse mythology
described the cosmic egg as the origin
of the world." The vernal equinox and
the cult of
Sibel. The worship of Syel, the great
mother involved the death and rebirth of
her
consort, again, her husband or lover,
Addis. Mirroring Addis is always has the
world on his shoulders, the earth, a
globe, mirroring later Christian
narratives about Christ. The rituals
involved eggs as symbols of the cycle of
life, death, and resurrection.
Wow. So looking at all this, you look at
all the all the things that have
happened in our
world, all these uh ritualistic things
like 9/11. It was all about destroying
the 11. Um you'll have to look into our
video. We did a video called the
deception is greater than we thought. It
has Trump on there with a golden calf
and it's talking
about the the numerology of 9 and 11.
What the symbology of 9 and 11 means and
it's death and rebirth and resurrection
all this stuff. And symbolically or
physically they had to destroy the
number 11 which the two the twin towers
were that physical embodiment of the 11.
Those towers came down and were replaced
with a single tower that was greater
than before called the one world tower.
And that's literally what the whole
ritual is about. You look into that
video. They did that. Now we're seeing
the the phoenix rising out of the ashes
was part of that ritual, that ceremony.
And now Trump is he was um oh man, what
is it? They four and five. He was the
45th president, which equals four and
five is nine. And then he was the Oh
man, I'm trying to get this right. 45
and anyway, you he was the first term he
was in, he was the
45th, 54th, I don't know. Anyway, watch
the video. He wears a hat that has two
numbers on the hat. When you add them
together, it's 911. Yeah. Now he's
coming out here talking about bringing
us into the golden age and there's this
egg stuff going on where
literally a physical 20 foot egg was
captured by some alien being. It's not
from human origin. They're telling us
Chris Bledsoe who is a outright open
Christian says that he's having
communications with a woman. We're going
to show the clip. Communications with a
woman who shows up on Easter every year.
Yeah. And he says Easter is a very
significant time for Christians is what
he's saying for Christians. But Easter
is a very significant time for Ishtar
and this woman that's coming to visit
him who he believes is the Holy Spirit.
I mean, just think about how deceived
humanity is right now. I mean, this is
utter Babylon. like complete confusion.
Okay,
here's a clip about the egg. Mhm.
Canada, the Republic of
Macedonia. There, isolated on a hill in
the middle of a vast step, sits a giant
geoglyph depicting a symbol known as the
cosmic
egg. According to ancient mythology, it
is the great egg of the universe.
from which a powerful deity is often
hatched or born.
The concept of the cosmic egg is
universal. But what's so interesting is
that a multinational team who have been
investigating this site have come to the
conclusion that it's orientated towards
the constellation of
Cassiopia. Cassiopia represents the
queen of heaven. Oh, in addition to the
alignment of the egg with the Cassiopia
constellation, many scholars believe
that the symbol contained in the egg
represents that of the cosmic god
S. He represents the allseeing
god. Macedonian myth says that the god
Se was the child of the great cosmic
mother and the supreme godfather.
While there are various theories as to
who made the cosmic egg geoglyph and
why, ancient astronaut theorists agree
on one
point that this geoglyph, like the
thousands of others found all across the
world, was intended to be more than
simply a work of art or indicate a place
of
worship. It was intended to communicate
something of great, possibly
intergalactic importance.
It would seem that extraterrestrials
arrived on Earth and then taught humans
the meanings of these symbols and then
humans then used these symbols to try
and contact the extraterrestrials
themselves either as giant geoglyphs on
the ground to even just petroglyphs on
the rocks.
Ancient astronaut theorists suggest that
the notion that petroglyphs and
geoglyphs could represent a form of
communication taught to humans by alien
visitors is supported by our own
relatively modern science of
semiodics. It is the study of signs and
symbols mankind will need to use when
trying to communicate not only with
future generations but with
extraterrestrials.
Pictographs are more than pretty
simplistic pictures. They are in fact
another way of communicating entirely,
not only on Earth, but in a spacecraft
sent to deep space to communicate
perhaps with beings we have no idea
about how they speak, write, or make
signification.
All right. Some people are saying the
clip seemed quiet, but it was talking
about uh that that egg hieroglyph that
you saw on the ground, the big giant
egg. It aligned with a constellation
that points to the queen of heaven. You
look up who the queen of heaven is in
the Bible, it's Ishtar. Mhm. And so when
you see the Catholic Church praying to
the queen of heaven, who are they
praying to? There is no queen of
heaven. Not in the biblical sense of
like, you know, God, he God's the king.
Who's the queen, right? There is no
queen, right? There is no queen. The
Bible talks about the queen of heaven
being um an abomination and they're
making these cakes to her and all this
stuff. And so when they when they're
pushing that stuff in
Catholicism and now we're seeing this
big push in the mainstream propaganda,
this this is History Channel. History
Channel is saying
that that this is real, that this we're
we're scientists and we communicate with
extraterrestrial beings and they're
trying to communicate with us and show
us this egg and this constellation about
the Queen of Heaven. And then you got a
Christian coming out who's having real
encounters with aliens that he believes
are good angels because they healed him.
He's deceiving thousands of people with
his testimony, saying that I was healed
of Crohn's by these aliens who are
actually good angels.
He says, "I communicate with Hathor."
Hatheror the the that's the Egyptian
goddess but she came it changed from the
Egyptian goddess Hatheror to Ishtar and
Ashtar Ishtar became known as Ashster in
the Bible or Ashira and God talks
directly about that in his Bible and he
says that he sees UFO alien crafts that
are the shape of an egg and now we got
news nation pushing that this military
guy obtained candidate. He's at the
congressional hearings. He's at
legitimate congressional hearings saying
UFOs are real. We've obtained them. We
talked to non-inhuman intelligences. We
talked to interdimensional beings. So,
this isn't just some cooks in a basement
somewhere. No, this is like this is
what's being forcefed to humanity right
now that this is real. This is
happening. If you're denying it, then
you're in denial basically because this
is real, right? Okay. So, more on this
Easter
connection. It says, "As you go about
this," Well, it's someone who wrote this
article is saying, "As you go about the
week, coloring eggs is the season
season, slicing boiled eggs for the
cedar plate, munching on egg-shaped
candles, or just having your morning
fried, scrambled, or boiled version."
Candies. Okay, you're not going to be
munching on candles, right? Candies.
Sorry, candies. Think on the venerable
mythic quality of this humble food,
which is also the source of birds,
reptiles, amphibians, and insects. The
egg has a very long history of primary
importance in mythology. There is an
ancient Egyptian picture of Tahudi, also
known as Thoth, holding the contempl and
contemplating a simple egg outlined
within the top loop of an enk, a symbol
of eternal life. Now, the ankh actually
is sun worship. I had someone actually
who is
a Egyptian Coptic tell me this because
they wore it around their neck all the
time. And Thoth is the very god that
Alistar Cwley liked to emulate and made
Thoth tarot cards
from. So going back to that now Thoth is
a major being within the Egyptian
pantheon. He is the ibis headed netter
god. So think a cow. Think the bull. No.
who hatched the world egg and who is the
inventor of hieroglyphs and thus
writing. He is very old god even by
Egyptian reckoning and was thought to be
very wise indeed. Thoth looking at the
egg in the ank seems to say this is it.
It's all here. Just open your mind to
it. Oh yeah summed up real nice. Do you
want to read that? Yeah. So this, you
know, Aubry is going to be covering this
topic very soon. Easter is coming in a
week and there's going to be lots of
Christians in the next few days
participating in this stuff. And you
cannot baptize paganism.
According to Barbara Walker in her in
her book, the woman's dictionary of
symbols and sacred objects, the common
idea of long of a long time ago was that
the universe was shaped like an egg. The
Egyptian goddess Hatheror, there it is,
whose worship predated even that of
Tahudi, Tahudi, was said to have
shapeshifted into the into a goose and
laid the golden egg, the sun itself at
the beginning of creation, the sun. So
she laid the sun, which is the golden
egg. In addition, Walker states that or
the cosmic egg of mystical iconography
carried all the Arabic numerals and
alphabet letter alphabetical letters.
Huh? It's Arabic. Oh, what did I say? I
don't know. Okay. Carried all the Arabic
numerals and alphabetical letters
combined with an ellip with an
ellipse. And to my mind that is
reminiscent of Thoth, the father of
Egyptian writings, holding that egg. So
you see right here, it's this is the
enk. You see the cross with the egg on
top which forms the enk. Mhm. But notice
we what we're seeing the egg, the
goddess
Hathor. This is on a page talking about
Easter because all this is going to be
coming together here in a second.
Yeah, right here. Chris Bledsoe
approached by a 45 foot eggshaped craft.
And he he's all he saw the eggshaped
craft. And what did he say in his
interview? Notice he says right here it
says Chris Bledsoe. This guy's a
self-professed Christian. If anybody
doesn't know who he is, um he's not just
some wacko out there either in the in
the corner of the internet. He's getting
interviewed and having millions of
views. Not on this page. This is
something else. He's being interviewed
by top podcasters and the CIA is
studying this guy a lot and he said he's
the most studied person by the CIA and
they're wanting to know what what he
knows about UFOs and he's a
self-professed Christian who has
communications with the Lady Hawthor
Bledsoe. At one point in the future, the
mother, Lady Hawthor, is going to allow
me to film her. Can you imagine when he
gets this footage? Can you imagine?
Okay, this is this guy is his interview
got over a million views in one day. And
the whole interview was about his
testimony of having encounters with
aliens and how he's a Christian and
believes that these are good angels that
flew in an eggshaped craft. and he talks
to the lady named Hathor who is a has a
cosmic bull. All this is what we just
went through. We are literally seeing
pagan gods in our world right now being
promoted by Christians as the Holy
Spirit. But also they're being
called extraterrestrials when they do
show themselves because it's it's all
coming together, right? Even the
newagers believe that aliens, even
though they fly around, you know, planet
to planet, they're some kind of
spiritual beings that you can channel
and communicate with. Everything is
coming together like like we've been
talking about. Sexuality, morality,
spiritual, physical, it's all merging.
It's all becoming this one thing to
where this
Christian calls Hatheror the Holy Spirit
and he's going to have footage of her.
Imagine when that hits the mainstream
news. He's finally going to get to film
her because he meets with her every
Easter every year since he's been having
these encounters. And this last time he
saw her, I don't know if it's in this
clip, she told him something very
significant. and it's going to happen on
Easter 2026. Mhm. And he says, "I don't
know what it is, and this is the first
time I've ever said it, but I think it's
going to be the return of Christ." What?
This is crazy, dude. Insane. Here's what
he says about her. I hope you guys can
hear it. And then in um 2013, let's fast
forward six years, the lady comes back.
She comes on Easter again and has pretty
much every year since Easter it's always
a special time when she comes.
So it I don't know if you guys can hear
or not but he's talking about how always
Easter always a special time in the
interview he had with with this other
guy. I can't remember his name now. He
said why do you think it's Easter? And
he goes well what's Easter? And the guy
said the resurrection. He goes Yep. He
to him Easter is a very special time
because he's associating it with the
resurrection of what he thinks is
Christ.
But think about this logically. If we
were going to memorialize the
anniversary of Christ's
resurrection, wouldn't it be on the same
day? We'd be like, "Oh yeah, he
resurrected April 5th. So every April
5th, we're going to celebrate the
resurrection of Christ, right? Yeah.
Anniversary is a certain date, a birth
date. My birthday is not like, well,
every third Sunday of November is my
birthday. No, it's the 3rd of November,
if you guys didn't know, right? It
doesn't change. And that's what his
point is. It shouldn't change. But this
is what the Catholic Church even calls
as a movable feast, they call it. And so
that means that it can always change
with the equinox. It's always based on
which is always sun and moon placement.
So why are we celebrating? Why are we
memorializing the anniversary of the
resurrection of Christ with the sun? Why
are we not keeping a date like Jesus
resurrected on this date and every year
it's the same day? And you guys, you
know, maybe you've already thought about
this like, oh, I this is such a
confusing uh holiday like it always
changes. Why? Ask yourself why. Because
it has nothing to do with an
anniversary. It has everything to do
with the sun. And that's what we're
finding out here,
right? Um, so the esoteric and occult
significance of the egg aligns with the
cosmic egg or mund mundane egg found in
alchemal, cabalistic, and hermetic
teachings. Some key parallels include
the rebirth of the sun, such as in
Luciferian beliefs, Easter is tied to
the spring equinox. There you go. When
the sun is resurrected after the long
winter, growing in strength. This
mirrors occult sun worship traditions
where deities linked to Lucifer, the
lightbearer, undergo death and rebirth.
The egg is the philosopher stone, which
is an alchemy. The egg represents the
sealed vessel in which the
transformation of base matter into gold
occurs, symbolizing spiritual
enlightenment or the ascension of man to
godhood. Easter eggs and esoteric
knowledge painted
eggs, particularly red ones, were used
in various mystery schools to symbolize
hidden wisdom and initiation rights.
carnal knowledge for sacrifice is what
they mean every
Easter and I've I've placed that there
and it says priests of Ishtar and Easter
or Easter would impregnate young virgins
on the altar of the goddess of the dawn
at sunrise in an orgy frenzy on Easter
Sunday. Nine months later, the priests
would then sacrifice the threemon-olds
on the altar and dye Easter eggs in the
blood of the infants. Wow. This is what
an Easter egg really is. Yeah. To
remember your sacrifice of the child
that you let be sacrificed and keep it
throughout the year and its meaning of
fertility. In Freemasonry, Theosophy,
and other occult
traditions, they embrace the cosmic egg
as a unifying
symbol. This connects to Easter in
several ways. Easter as a time of
initiation for them. Some occult
traditions view Easter as a time when
hidden knowledge again that hidden
knowledge of what what did they call it?
It was sacrifices and sex come into play
is revealed. They say aligning with the
mystery school initiations that took
place during spring festivals,
meaning Easter.
Yep. So, I I just think this is so
interesting because if this guy Chris
Bledsoe is really getting the attention
he's getting and he's saying, I'm going
to get a video of Ishtar. She's going to
let me video her. and Ishtar came to
Earth in an egg and they're
finding 20 foot eggs in real
life. They have video evidence of it. I
mean, this is like the gods of old are
coming back. And that's like what 2025
is all about. That's what Alice Bailey
was saying or or Helen Blovski, I don't
remember that that in the year 2025, we
would be seeing the externalization of
the hierarchy. The gods are coming back.
Yes. On video. We did have that in here.
I hope we're coming to that. Do we? Yep.
It should be coming still.
So here we we have to first address the
fact of how did the world come to
worshiping or keeping Easter? It was the
Vatican's adoption of Easter that made
it happen. With its egg symbolism, it
suggests that it is in that it
incorporated ancient pagan fertility
rights into Christian traditions. The
Mary Mary was used as the queen of
heaven. The Catholics venerated Mary as
the queen of heaven which parallels
Ishtar or Easter worship who is also
called the queen of heaven. In the
Vatican and
ecumenicism, by blending fertility
symbols like eggs into its practices,
the church subtly aligns itself with the
larger esoteric push for religious
unification, a key element of ecumenical
monism. If the cosmic egg represents the
merging of all things, male and female,
all religions, all spiritual paths, then
Easter as a celebration of rebirth could
be seen as part of a larger movement
towards religious synratism. Again,
synratism is the same thing as monism.
All of them coming together as one
singularity. Yes. So we have Pope
Francis's interfaith initiatives that he
held which says the Vatican is heavily
involved in interfaith dialogues. We
know that. Yeah. Which seeks to unify
Christianity, Islam, Judaism and other
world religions under one doctrine. In
the occult vision of the new age or
sorry the new golden age, you have the
new age movement. Theosophy and
Freemasonry foresee a future where all
belief systems emerge into a universal
spirituality. The egg representing
rebirth and unity could symbolize this
very
transformation. I'm just I'm trying to
like recap as we go because I don't want
people to forget what we're talking
about. Trump's saying we're entering a
golden
age. That's exactly what this is talking
about. Easter's about to come. Chris
Bledsoe is gonna show video evidence of
a woman that he says is the Holy
Spirit. Because why? Because all of
this, this is going to cause every
person on earth to rethink everything.
Even if you're an atheist now, you're
going to have to rethink everything
because I see a God who's come in an egg
from the heavens. And they're going to
say, "Look, we everybody's had these
different beliefs. Some believed in the
Bible. Some believed in the etchings on
the walls. Some believed in the aliens
up there. It's all the same. We all have
to unite in agreement on this because we
are really all one. We're all God's
people. We're all God's children. That's
what Reagan said in that um speech he
gave in the United Nations. He said,
"How how all our differences would go
away if we were threatened by some alien
force and we would all recognize that
we're all God's children." That's
exactly what's going to happen. We're
going to have to stop bickering about
all the differences and nuances and is
it the Bible or is it the what the
pagans believe or is it aliens? No, it's
we all believe the same thing. And you
don't think that those statements that
were made by the presidents like that
were actually all setups for this very
movement. It was a another clue of where
we were going. Yep. Where they want us
to be going. Man, this is this is going
to be crazy. And we have to be prayed up
and
be ready for Christ's return. We have to
be ready for first before Christ
returns. We got to be ready to face a
major deception
that the whole world is going to fall
for. How do you deceive the entire world
like this? Atheists are going to have to
rethink. Christians are going to have to
rethink. Muslims, Buddhists,
everything's going to have to rethink
everything.
Mhm. Okay. So, we read through that
again. This is proof that Oh, yeah. We
should have talked about this does it
does move and it doesn't stay the same.
Um, movable feast. I I'm not really sure
we need to read through that, but this
is actual proof for that. Yeah, this is
what we were kind of uh ad living, but
here's here's a proof. So the date of
Easter is determined by calculating the
first Sunday after the full moon that
occurs on or after the ven ver vnerable
vernal equinox. This calculation is
called computus whatever it's something
in Latin for Easter. Uh Easter is a
movable feast. So it doesn't happen on
the same time. So this is just proof
that Easter has nothing to do with an
anniversary of when Christ resurrected.
It's everything to do with the the moon.
Yeah. The luminaries up there.
Yep. Okay. So, I'm just going to read
the portion that's highlighted. We're
talking about Samuris, which is Nimrod's
wife. It
says, "She further claimed that she came
down from the moon in a giant moon egg
that fell into the Euphrates River."
This was the same as Ishtar because why
Samuris became
known? She was one of the first people
to become known as Ishtar Asher and so
on. This was to have happened at the
time of the first full moon after the
spring equinox just when we see Easter
happening all the time. Y so Mis became
known as Ishtar. There we go. Which is
pronounced Easter. And her moon egg
became known as Ishtar's egg. I want to
read right here. We jump down to right
here. It says the ancient druids.
Oh, sorry. Oops. Let's go back. The
ancient druids.
Okay. Right here. Bore an egg as a
sacred emblem of their order.
Wow. Druids. So, I mean, just keep this
in mind. Mhm. Ishtar
simmeris. What? Samis
came down in a giant egg. We're seeing
what they're calling nonhuman
crafts that are 20 foot eggs, right?
Okay. So, here's where we need to
understand Easter as a hidden occult
celebration. Easter though its use of
eggs may not be merely may not be merely
a Christian celebration of Christ's
resurrection. Instead, it appears to be
a continuation of ancient mystery
traditions that venerate the cosmic egg
as a source of rebirth, initiation, and
ultimate unification of all spiritual
paths. Given its alignment with
fertility goddesses, as it mentions
goddesses, you do have Samir, Ishtar,
Hatheror, and so on. Alchemal
transformations and Freemasonic ideals.
It may play a role in ushering a new age
religious order, one that seeks to unite
all faiths into a single monistic
doctrine. That's exactly what is
happening. That's what the Bible says is
going to happen. It's what we see
literally unrolling before our very
eyes.
Okay. So, here's where we see that Alice
Bailey, I'll just jump down right away
about this golden age. She mentions
2025 as the externalization of the
hierarchy, meaning the visible return of
the occult world leaders would begin,
which would be Ishtar and Hatheror and
all those pagan gods.
And this this time of unification, the
Vatican's ecumenical push, Pope Francis
and other globalist religious figures
have accelerated interfaith unity,
pointing towards the cosmic egg's goal
of merging all beliefs. Wow. Indeed, it
is bale worship. That is true.
So, the cosmic egg is not just an
ancient myth, but a
blueprint for the esoteric and occult
vision of world transformation. It is a
vessel of alchemal rebirth, a symbol of
unity and the initiation point of a new
age. This aligns perfectly with a cult
globalism, freemasonry, and theosophical
uh teachings that anticipate a coming
golden age where all religions,
spiritualities, and dualities dissolve
into one. Now they're summing it up
again. The occult cosmic egg equals the
incubation chamber of the new world
order. The golden age equals the
completion of the great work where
mankind becomes divine. Wow. The coming
2025 shift well is the cracking of the
cosmic egg leading to the full unveiling
of the new age. Ultimately, the cosmic
egg in this context serves as Satan's
counterfeit version of God's true
redemption and new creation, promising
enlightenment while leading humanity
into deception.
Wow. I mean, this is this is really
surreal. Mhm. You know, I I don't know
if people really realize how deceptive
these last days are going to be. They
think, "Well, I know that they're going
to be, you know, there there's a big
misconception in the Christian world,
actually. They think because of all
these left behind movies and stuff that
we're going to get a really evil
president and he's going to hate
Christianity. He's going to kill
Christians in the street and be openly
abusive and torturous and persecuting
because they hear that word antirist."
And they think, "Oh, that means he's
against Christ." But Antichrist means
you're you're substituting Christ.
You're like replacing Christ. Think of
like the Bizarro world like Superman and
Bizaro Superman or whatever. It's you're
impersonating Christ. Mhm. And and it's
not going to be so obvious. It's going
to be the biggest deception in human
history. It's not going to be all the
Christians are being killed in the
street. It's going to look like, oh,
you're a Christian. Awesome. I'm
Buddhist and you're Muslim and we all
have the same God. Come on over. Like,
let's go to church together. And if you
stand on thus sayeth the Lord, the Ten
Commandments, and what the Bible says,
you're going to be public enemy number
one. Right? But when all this stuff
comes out, you're how are you going to
convince people? I don't care what they
found. I don't care about the video he
has of of the Holy Spirit, who also is
Hatheror. I don't care if you find 20
foot eggs that are coming from space.
You're gonna look like you're gonna be
the crazy one because you're gonna say,
"I don't care what they find. I still
believe this and and you're going to
look like some religious zealot that is
against peace and unity and they coexist
because it looks so loving." Like the
pope said, "Look, my God's not better
than your God. We all have the same God
and we're all different languages to the
same God." I'm sorry. We have a lot to
get through, so I'm trying to speed this
along a bit. Um
so why is this whole sex thing
important? Well in esoteric traditions
including cabala, hermeticism, theosophy
and freemasonry focus on the
hyros gamos like we said sacred marriage
which symbolizes the merging of the male
and female forces to create divine
wholeness. Right? We saw that in the
reebus picture in alchemy. This is the
reebus. There we go. which is depicting
depicted standing inside the cosmic egg.
I think we read this already actually.
Yes, we did. Okay, this is a copy.
Sorry. So, breaking out of your egg, why
and how all people are meant to do so.
This is according to the occult. So,
let's get into this. In the occult, new
age gnostic and luciferian systems of
belief, the idea of hatching from one's
egg is deeply symbolic of the spiritual
awakening of the self as God. a personal
aapotheosis or alchemal
rebirth. This concept is central to
hermeticism, alchemy, theosophy,
Crowleyian magic, again with a K. Yep.
And even some modern
psychological mysticism.
It often involves a process of inner
transformation through practices like
meditation, ritual sex, channeling
entities, and altered consciousness to
crack the shell of limitation, morality,
duality, and separation. There you go.
It says it right there. This is on
research gate, but it's from the red
book by Carl Jung, the the well-known
psychologist that we all seem to, I
don't know, study in college and all
that. and also from universal co-masonry
Helen Bllovsky and her book the secret
doctrine. All right. So we we read about
a little more. The cosmic egg is not
just a symbol of the universe. It also
represents the individual self
particularly the higher self trapped
inside layers of illusion, duality and
ignorance. Whatnosticism calls the false
material prison. In this framework, the
shell represents the ego, religious
dogma, societal morality, or the
illusion of separation from
divinity. This goal is to the goal is to
break free from that shell and be reborn
as a divine being, a self-created god.
This mirrors Lucifer's rebellion and the
serpent's offer to Eden to Eve in Eden.
You shall be as
gods to hatch from the egg and awaken
one's divine potential. The occult
systems prescribed various methods that
involve spiritual initiation, often
mimicking birth or
transformation. Number one, meditation,
channeling, and contact with ascended
ascended masters or extraterrestrials.
This is in Theosophy with Helen Bvotski
and Alice Bailey. The egg cracks through
ascension, meditation, and spiritual
discipline, allowing contact with
ascended masters, spirit guides, and
divine extraterrestrial beings. This
contact is considered telepathic,
astral, or even
physical as in CE-5 contact methods
promoted in the new age
circles. These beings are often
portrayed as lightbringers like
Luciferian archetypes guiding humanity
into a new age. This is from the
theosophy Theosophical or Theosophy
Society. So when you see that
C5, that guy Jake Barber who picked up
that egg, the CIA and him, they are
practicing this right now. Like you can
watch them. You can they have night
vision glasses and they're out there and
they're they said we are connecting with
these beings through C5. They put these
things on their head, all these suction
cups on their head and they start
meditating with their eyes closed or
blindfolded
and and they
are summoning these UFOs and
communicating with them telepathically.
This is right now happening right now in
the military and televised. If you
haven't seen it, go to NewsNation and
check out uh just type eggshaped craft
news and you'll see this is exactly what
they're doing right now. Right. So, this
is a picture. It was on one of the books
that I've read to get some understanding
on this aboutnosticism and esotericism.
It shows what you're supposed to be
doing is peeking your head like this
man. Can you through the firmament right
through the firmament wall into the
divine perfect world that you're
supposed to get enlightenment and be
freed of illusion from. So I just
thought it was interesting. It's right
there. Notice the sun, moon, and stars
are all inside this firmament egg.
That's what they uh believe. I I believe
this image too, but not in the sense
that they do. Right. So this is straight
from the wild hunt pagan news and
perspectives. It's called reclaiming the
sexual self through magic and ritual.
This is proof that they do. So they use
that as a way to do
that. And that's all I needed for that.
But it's
also the other method we're on. We
talked about the first method. Now this
is the second method that they say the
occult world uses, which is ritual sex
and
tantric alchemy. Tantric is usually in
sexual eroticism as well. Um but in the
Crowleyian sex magic and lefthand path
practices, sexual rituals are creative
acts of rebirth. The ora orgasm is used
to collapse duality, male and female,
light and darkness and unlock divine
potential within the
practitioner. The egg in this context
becomes both womb and grave. You die to
the old self and are reborn as a god.
These rituals often involve in invoking
spirits, gods or demons. And in this in
some elite circles even include ritual
abuse and perversion as a form of
liberation from morality. This is why
they do ritual abuse symbol symbolically
cracking the shell of
conscience. They use also psychedelics
and shaman sham shamanic rebirth. In the
new age and occult traditions, they
often use plant medicines like ohasa DMT
to shatter ego boundaries and initiate
and initiate a death rebirth experience.
The user descends into a void which is
the egg and then returns reborn or
enlightened stripping stripped of
illusion often claiming to have merged
with universal consciousness. The
entities encountered in these states are
often masquerading spirits appearing as
benevolent extraterrestrials, light
beings or guides, but many report them
having parasitic or even demonic
characteristics. This is from Helen
Bllovsky's book, The Secret Doctrine and
Shamanism 101.
And we do see that like um you got
people like Joe Rogan who's the biggest
podcaster out there and he's promoting
this
DMT Mike Tyson's done it. All these
people are saying that they shattered
their ego. They they have they ego death
is what they call it. They've been
enlightened. Yep.
So they also have symbolic initiation
through ritual that they use to do this.
In Freemasonry and other secret
societies, initiation rituals often
involve death and rebirth symbolism,
symbolizing the soul's escape from the
egg of ignorance using rape, murder,
etc. as ways to do this. The initiate is
born again into the light of Lucifer,
though it's cloaked in moral language
and allegory.
This is from morals and dogmas, one of
the Freemason books by Albert
Pike. So, hatching from the egg is a
gnostic counterfeit of being born again
in Christ. It is not a death to sin, but
a death to divine authority, replacing
submission to God with worship of the
self. Wow. This divine birth is often
characterized by becoming your own god,
which is taught in Timma. Another occult
belief to do what thou wilt shall be the
whole of the law. Rejecting duality,
good and evil does not exist. Male and
female should not exist. Light and dark
and embracing unity
consciousness. Spiritual monism. The
belief that all is one and there is no
creator or creation distinction.
Liberation from guilt, shame, or moral
um consequence. Seen as outdated
constraints of a lower consciousness.
So no more biblical righteousness. It is
seen as slavery. Yep. We see that in our
mentality already. I mean everybody's
like all the songs, everything is
talking about do what you want to do.
It's all pushing do what thou wilt. You
are your own god. There is no
morality. Uh and anything that's
biblical that's that's outdated slavery
of humanity basically. Right? I used to
believe that way.
Okay. The biblical counterpoint, Satan's
false birth. From a biblical worldview,
all of these practices are part of
Satan's master deception, offering false
enlightenment, false power, and false
resurrection. Satan masquerades as an
angel of light. We see in 2 Corinthians
11:14, the rebirth offered in Christ is
through repentance and spiritual renewal
only. It says in John 3:3, not
selfdeification or ritual magic. We saw
the word apotheiois, which some have
also linked
to Washington on the ceiling of the
rotunda, which is where Trump was
inaugurated. Correct. Yeah. And that
plays a big role in this. This does play
a part in that. But we will cover that
also later tomorrow.
But apo
apothis means to be deified to become
your own god. So yes, they're talking
about
that. So it is not selfdeification
they're saying or ritual magic. It's
supposed to be through Christ through
repentance and spiritual renewal alone.
The cosmic egg in a cult practice is a
counterfeit Eden where man attempts to
take the place of God through forbidden
knowledge or nosis being gnostic. The
shellbreaking of the egg is Satan's
version of the resurrection, a
blasphemous imitation of Christ's rising
from the tomb. Wow.
There's more proof right here if you
want it first. Oh, it goes through it
again. First or 2 Corinthians 11:14,
"And no wonder, for Satan himself
masquerades an angel of light." John
3:3, Jesus replied, "Very truly I tell
you, no one can see the kingdom of God
unless they are born again." Genesis
3:5, "For God knows that when you eat
from it, your eyes will be opened, and
you will be like God, knowing good and
evil."
2 Thessalonians 2:11, "For this reason,
God sends them a powerful delusion so
that they will believe the lie." So,
this is the the lie that originated from
Satan in the garden that you can be as
gods. And it I mean, it's went through
thousands of years. We are still
believing the lie. And people are
embracing it more than ever. I would say
maybe. I mean, we know we're coming into
the days of Noah, the days of Sodom,
Gomorrah, and so those times were were
probably just as wicked as now. But we
are definitely racing towards that time
again. That was the last
slide. What happened? Our camera got cut
off. Man, we've been having some trouble
today.
Thank you guys for sticking with us
through two hours. This is Chloe, our
little mascot. She's always laying in
our lap. You guys don't know it, but we
are coming towards some very deceptive
times. And we're not prepared for it. I
I'll tell you that hands down. We are
not prepared for what is about to come.
We're about to see physical
manifestations of literally fallen
angels masquerading as aliens as
um we're going to see false
gods physically manifest on
camera. Uh crafts that have been
obtained. We are not ready for what's
coming. And so this was supposed to be a
a shaking, a wakeup call, an alarm
sounding because we're supposed to be
the watchmen, right? We're the watchmen
that are waking up God's
people. And I I just I don't want people
to fall for the the deception that, oh,
the last days, yeah, it's going to be
rough, but you know, I'll die for Christ
and all that stuff. It's going to be so
more deceptive than that. so deceptive
that millions of Christians are going to
fall for this. It's going to be a false
revival. If this is new to you, I mean,
I I encourage you guys, I urge you,
please study outside of the Left Behind
series. And um I was looking at the
wrong camera this whole time.
Please look into this topic because
prophecy it's so amazing and when we
have the proper understanding of it
that's the only way that we will not
fall for this deception of the last
days. There is so much false doctrine in
the church today. The teaching of a
pre-tribulation rapture like we're all
going to be sucked out of here. We're
not going to be here for that. I don't
even need to study about what the
antichrist is or what the mark of the
beast is or any of that stuff. That is
the biggest deception. And what happens
when you die? Oh, people aren't really
dead. They're still here. And all these
deceptive lies that have been taught in
the church are setting us up for this
grand
final deception. And it's going to be
huge. It's going to
be if we didn't have the Bible, if we
didn't have the truth, 100% we'd all
fall for it because this is what
humanity wants. I won't believe it till
I see it. Show me and I'll believe it.
Well, they're going to they're going to
show themselves. And we as
uh Christians who have an understanding
of the truth, we are going to be the
biggest outcasts ever. But we have to to
cling to the promises of God that all of
this is going to all of this no matter
what we go through, no matter what we
face, no matter if our family turns on
us because we know Jesus says you'll be
hated for my name's sake. You must
forsake father and mother if you have
to. But it will all be worth it. We're
going to get to heaven and say heaven
was cheap enough.
All the things of this world mean
nothing in comparison to eternal life
and a perfect kingdom. I pray that you
guys believe the same way. If this was
eye openening to you, please share this
video. Please give it a thumbs up. It
really helps us get into the algorithm.
We love you guys. We can't do this
without you. If you guys want to support
this channel, you can do so by going to
candidtruth.org. We got many different
ways of giving. This the only way we can
do this, guys. We We can't do this
without you. And we thank you all so
much. Those people who are giving
weekly, monthly, randomly, we love you.
We thank you. We can't do this without
you guys. Thank you so much for making
this possible. If you guys like
t-shirts, we got a lot of cool t-shirts
on the website. I'm wearing one right
now that says, "Be cool. Use your
brain." Um, there's a lot of other ones
out there. Like I said, we can't do this
without you guys. We love you. We thank
you. Thank you for being here. And don't
forget to like, share, and subscribe.
And we will see you next time on Candid
Truth.